welcome to the daily climate show coming
up a canary in the coal mine bird
watchers are excited over new faces in
norfolk but what does it tell us about
climate change
the g7 is failing to provide the money
it promised to help vulnerable nations
deal with the impacts of climate change
and the eu accuses russia of weaponizing
russian gas as 12 countries now face
cuts to supply
[Music]
hello welcome to the daily climate show
where we track the changes happening to
our planet hear from the people affected
by them and report on the race for
solutions and we start today with news
of some unexpected visitors bird
watchers have been flocking to the
norfolk coast to see european bee eaters
rare and spectacular visitors from
africa and southern europe
exciting for bird watchers no doubt but
also a sign that climate change has
arrived our science and technology
editor tom clark reports
a beater in britain that's rare enough
these blue green and gold insect feeders
are native to africa southern spain and
portugal but there's been holiday
romance then the digging of a nest
burrow in which the adults are now
spending hours in shifts a sure sign
they're attempting to breed
and for birders that's about as exciting
as it gets north norfolk's never seen so
much high-end optics when you compare
them to a natural bird of the uk
you don't get to see so many bright
colors but they're they're just a myriad
of rainbow of colors there's super
little things to watch to see something
so colorful and the fact that they might
actually nest here is just a bird
watcher's dream the behaviour the way
they're swooping in flight the call
the rarity
um the way they catch insects on the
wing it's just
just fantastic birds to watch first
seven now eight european beaters have
been hanging around this quarry for more
than a week
since word got out last week more than 2
000 visitors have come to see them the
rspb and local birders have set up a car
park and cordon to minimise disturbance
of course a bird as rare and beautiful
as a bee eater attempting to breed in
the uk is going to draw a bit of a crowd
but its presence here is significant for
another reason and that's because of
what it says about our rapidly warming
climate
beta's made an attempt to breed in the
uk in 1950 but since 2000 there have
been six nesting attempts
the last in 2017 failed due to bad
weather it really is hit or miss because
you know they are arriving in a country
that they previously haven't bred in um
and so you know it's
quite stressful for them as a species
it's a clear link between climate and
nature crisis they've got to you know
obviously feed themselves um and we are
you know in a very nature depleted
country um
so you know if there is then a
kind of large population in the uk we
have to take that on as world leaders
and and protect those those species
while the climate may be shifting in
their favor experience tells the rspb
over-eager twitchers or worse egg
collectors might disturb the birds
so they're now watching the nest site 24
hours a day letting nature take its
course through our changing times
tom clark sky news north norfolk
well as drought worsens across the horn
of africa threatening the lives and
livelihoods of millions of people a
senior kenyan official says it's
disappointing that developed nations
aren't honoring their climate finance
pledges the comments from the kenyan
official responsible for tackling
climate change comes as a new report
reveals rich nations are breaking
promises over climate finance in 2009
wealthy nations promised that by 2020
they would provide a hundred billion
dollars every year
in funding to help developing nations
mitigate against and adapt to climate
change well that target is not being met
and the report from the care climate
justice center says that over the past
decade nearly half of the funds reported
as climate finance by g7 nations have
simply been diverted from existing aid
budgets
well as g7 leaders gather in germany
this weekend developing nations are
calling for them to live up to their
promises
well i'm joined now from malawi by
chikandi chabuta who is with care
climate justice center
who produced the report good afternoon
to you thanks very much indeed for
speaking to us here on the uh daily
climate show these are
eye-opening numbers shocking some might
say
what do you make of this expose of
that you've found of how countries are
behaving in terms of climate finance
thank you very much
this report has really exposed that
promises are made but delivery is not
fully implemented
we've had commitments that have been
made from rich countries on ending
poverty that is to meet the sustainable
development goals
and now the commitments that were made
to
level up new and additional climate
finance this means it had to be new
separate from the development aid we are
working towards attaining development
just like the rich countries and now we
are being hit by climatic impacts
actually leaving them just
just last season we've had two months of
rainfall meaning that we have to have
finance that is to help us find food for
this winter season so that we have
enough to carry us until the next
growing season yeah so it's a double
whammy of sorts isn't it really because
uh one of the exposes your report found
as well is that as you say development
funding that should be attributed to
development that's health education uh
food and such like um is being diverted
to replace climate finance so it's a
double whammy because you're suffering
both on the development side but also on
the lack of new climate financing
that's correct i am looking at my
cousins who are in the village who are
unable to attend full education because
of lack of teachers on the ground that
is supposed to be oda and now they also
have to look at the just last cyclone
anna that has washed away their cropping
meaning they have to have actions on how
they adapt to those conditions so now
they are failing to do that but then
they also have to look at the burden of
seeing how do we cope up with the lack
of teachers lack of materials in the
classroom
so it is really disappointing to see
that countries make commitments make
promises but never leave out to them and
it has consequences on us or in the
developing countries and leaving the
climate impacts
so let's talk about what's really needed
in terms of real money i i notice as
well your report points out there is a
huge gap in the endorsements and the
pledges the kind of pr side of it all at
these various conferences like cop and
then the actual money coming to the
table what's needed how much and who
needs to step up
you know in in 2009 it was a promise to
say by 2020 we'll have a hundred billion
that even just scratches the surface of
the impacts that we are leaving and yet
what we have seen through this report
and also through other reports is that
money that was meant to be going towards
development is not being reported as
climate finance so what we are seeing is
sort of like a trick there's a trickery
that's going on where we have rich
countries not wanting to live up to the
commitments because when it comes to
climate finance this is finance that's
coming in for industrialized nations
effects on us the global south that
never played a role and we are saying
for us we need to also live up to
development find funds that are climatic
actions they are not living up to that
so everything and anything that's coming
to the global south is being reported as
climate finance and we feel that's
unfair
yeah chikandi chavuta we're going to
leave it there thanks very much indeed
it's the u.s the uk canada front and
italy who are doing the worst apparently
let's get some more of the day's other
climate news for you now and the eu's
climate chief has warned a full gas
disruption in europe is now more likely
than ever before due to the ongoing war
in ukraine we were discussing this
yesterday weren't we franz timmermans
was speaking after several eu countries
decided to revert to coal the most
powerful polluter of course as the gas
supply from russia reduces
russia has weaponized energy and we have
seen further gas disruptions
announced
in recent days
um all this is part of russia's strategy
to undermine our unity
in total 12 member states are now
affected by russian unilateral supply
cuts 10 member states have issued an
early warning under the gas security of
supply regulation
so
the risk of
a full gas disruption is now more real
than ever before
wildfires are raging for a third day
near a popular resort in southwest
turkey more than 2
500 firefighters have been deployed near
marmaris on the aegean sea coast the
fire spread rapidly and has forced
dozens of people from their homes the
scenes have sparked fears of a repeat of
last year's fires that were turkey's
worst on record and destroyed tens of
thousands of acres of woodland
new zealand is experiencing the largest
bleaching of sea sponges ever recorded
as unusually high ocean temperatures
turns millions of them white bleaching
lowers the chemical defenses of sea
sponges and deprives them of food needed
to survive two marine heat waves in the
country have created record ocean
temperatures rising as much as five
degrees higher than normal in some areas
that's all from us thanks for watching
back to you anna
[Music]